morning folks
could you be here today
i want to thank everybody for coming
this morning
ottawa residents are frustrated and they
are angry
and they have every right to be
their lives continue to be severely
impacted by
unlawful
and unsafe events
on the city streets in downtown core
and in the surrounding neighborhoods
this is unacceptable
this morning we've begun implementing a
new surge and contained strategy in our
downtown core
based on lessons learned over the last
operating cycle of the demonstrations
and new intelligence gathered literally
in the last 24 hours
there are three parts to this new
strategy
number one
we're deploying a surge of police
officers in the downtown
and the immediate neighborhoods
there will be approximately
150 additional officers
dedicated to only patrolling and
addressing unlawful threatening conduct
in the most impacted neighborhoods
specifically center town
lower town
and the byrd market
this surge will include working with our
city and ncr official partners to
prevent unlawful and unsafe use of
public spaces by demonstrators
these officers and our partners will be
focused on illegal activity
associated with the demonstrators
the surge will deliver a clear message
to the demonstrators
the lawlessness must end
the focus of these officers
will be on acts of mischief
hate
harassment
intimidation
and other threatening behaviors
second part of the strategy
will be an expansion of the hardening of
the perimeter
in the demonstration red zone the
immediate area of wellington street in
front of the parliament buildings
will be further isolating and containing
the demonstration in that red zone
the audible police service the city of
ottawa and our partners will be
utilizing concrete barriers
heavy equipment barricades to create no
access roadways throughout the downtown
core
this includes considerations
around the closing
of bridges
highway off ramps and other roadways
incoming protester vehicles today and
throughout the weekend will be directed
to designated parking zones outside of
the downtown core
illegal parking by demonstrators will
result in bylaw enforcement removal and
impound if necessary
again
interprovincial bridges highway off
ramps and roads
will be closed as needed as we manage
and monitor the influx of vehicles
and the egress of vehicles from the core
the third part of the strategy
enhanced intelligence and investigation
operations we now have secured fully
national provincial and local
intelligence agencies
we have increased ability to identify
and target protesters
and supporters of protesters
who are funding
and enabling
unlawful and harmful activity by the
protesters themselves
investigative evidence gathering teams
are collecting financial
digital vehicle registration
driver identification
insurance status and other related
evidence that will be used in
prosecutions
every unlawful act including traffic and
insurance violations will be fully
pursued regardless of the origin
at any time in the future
the primary focus of each of these
measures will be on the unlawful
behavior connected to the ongoing
demonstrations this includes parallel
and counter demonstrations
we strongly urge all demonstrators and
those engaging with the demonstrators to
act lawfully peacefully
and respectfully
the hatred the violence the illegal acts
that ottawa residences and businesses
have endured over the last week is
unacceptable in any circumstance
the ottawa police service in the city of
ottawa are bringing significantly
greater resources to restore order hold
offenders to account and protect our
neighborhoods
the current demonstration in the
parliamentary precinct red zone remains
unresolved despite significant successes
in reducing the number of trucks and
demonstrators while preventing riots
injuries or deaths
we take no solace in these operational
successes to date
our goal is to end the demonstration
the demonstrators in the red zone area
remain highly organized
well-funded
extremely committed to resisting all
attempts to end the demonstration safely
this remains as it was from the
beginning an increasingly volatile and
increasingly dangerous demonstration
the ottawa police service continues to
work with the national security agencies
the rcmp
the opp and other municipal police
agencies
over the last 48 hours we've also been
able to engage all three levels of
government
to affect a safe
timely and lawful end to this unlawful
and unacceptably dangerous demonstration
public safety remains paramount
as does our commitment to work with all
levels of government and all parts of
civil society to bring this
demonstration to an end
in closing i want to reiterate what
ottawa residents have endured what
ottawa businesses have endured
what our own service members and our
partners have endured over the last week
is unacceptable
and we have learned from our experience
we have gathered new evidence we have
secured new allies and we're
implementing new measures to bring this
demonstration to an end
thank you very much should be pleased to
take any questions we have at this time
good morning chief marika walsh with the
global mail i'd like to go broad first
and talk about trust residents in ottawa
feel that the police have broken the
trust they see the police helping
protesters direct them to where they
should be bringing their fuel cans of
jerry cans and they see propane tanks
stockpiles near the canal
whereas the police in the past and
enforcement in the past has meant that
things like a lemonade stand can
continue so how do you speak to
residents how do you explain and how do
you ensure that trust is rebuilt now
when they
thank you very much for your question
and again i take great empathy with
those that have endured unacceptable
violations of their ability to live and
raise their families and conduct their
businesses in the city in their
neighborhoods particularly during this
time almost two full years into a global
pandemic with everything that everybody
has suffered and endured
i have met with those business owners i
have met with the residents i've
patrolled in these streets and i can see
plainly and understand clearly
the depth of frustration that they have
in the police service and in society as
a whole to what they find here happening
today
we are doing everything we possibly can
to keep them safe
we are doing more and more each day as
we learn and understand the nature of
this demonstration how it is supported
funded sustained and committed to
continuing on despite best efforts by
policing partners here and across the
country
we're absolutely committed to bringing
this demonstration to an end
we've implemented major new efforts
150 new officers
based on the
intelligence will be applied in those
three neighborhoods most impacted where
that trust has been most impacted
24 hours a day over the next four days
coming through this weekend those
officers will be focused on enforcement
bringing to order and bringing to
justice those who have committed
disorder and unlawful acts to support
those residents and support those
businesses and rebuild that shake and
trust but it will take more than the
efforts of our officers to bring this
demonstration to an end and we have
gathered allies and supports from all
three levels of policing and public
safety and all three levels of
government
we are implementing new measures and we
are encouraged by the new measures that
others in our ally group are considering
and implementing right now as well
just wondering does that mean because
you talk about enforcing bylaw and
towing and impounding vehicles what
about the trucks on wellington does that
mean that you're going to start today
removing
trucks from that
area
thank you very much for your question
sir
we have been enforcing the bylaws the
provincial offenses act the criminal
code
we've been reducing the number of trucks
in the entire city of ottawa and
particularly in the downtown core
including in the red zone of wellington
the number of protesters have dropped
off significantly the number of trucks
in the red zone and the surrounding
neighborhoods have dropped off
significantly people have been arrested
and charged
offenses have been dealt with through
bylaw and provincial statutes evidence
is being gathered
investigations are ongoing including the
criminal investigation to the
desecration of the cenotaph that has
been going on since the beginning of
this demonstration and will continue on
certainly the criminal code
investigations will criminal will
continue on in perpetuity there is no
statute of limitations on criminal
investigations until we bring those who
committed those criminal acts to justice
in regards to a timeline for when we'll
remove all aspects of this demonstration
including the trucks in the red zone i
do not have a timeline now but as i've
stated before every option is on the
table
thank you for your question sir
good morning chief natalie van roy from
ctv ottawa vulnerable people feel
abandoned and harassed in their own city
how did you let the protesters gain so
much control
thank you very much for your question
i've had the opportunity in my patrols
over the last week to speak with some of
those vulnerable people i can tell you
it's heartbreaking
in fact as i was parked right up front
of this police station on a board
briefing with my board chair in regards
to where we were in the early part of
the week two members who live in the
ymca just on the other side of this
building came by in their wheelchairs
both of them elderly both of them
clearly struggling with a range of
disabilities doing their own shopping in
sub-zero temperatures they stopped to
speak with me they expressed their
frustration and their fear they also
expressed their understanding for the
incredibly difficult job that we're
doing and for the work that we've done
to support them thus far i understand
there is a wide range of opinions around
the efficacy of our efforts to date but
we've done absolutely the best we can to
keep this city safe to keep
residents like that safe the most
marginalized often the most racialized
communities as safe as we can we need to
do better we're committed to doing
better we now have more intelligence and
allies to do better and we're
implementing more and better plans a
hundred and fifty officers in these
neighborhoods to support people like
those two people i spoke about 150
officers 24 7 over the next four days no
matter how many trucks come into this
town those officers will remain
dedicated to keeping those vulgar
members as safe as they can be and
addressing unlawful and unacceptable
behavior in their neighborhoods until
the end of these demonstrations that is
my commitment here today
we will step up our intelligence and
investigation efforts we will hold to
account not just the demonstrators but
those that fund and enable the
demonstrators in any way
and we will have a hardened plan for the
weekend's demonstrations including
concrete barriers expanding that red
zone and locking down bridges highways
and major through fares to reduce the
ability of vehicles and trucks to come
in and when they come in to target them
ticket them and remove them as best we
can
thank you very much for your question
chief mckenzie gray with cb national
news you've spoken previously about how
you think some of the protesters have
guns is the ottawa police not willing to
move into the protesters because you
think if you do things will turn violent
thank you very much for your question
to be clear
we have already made arrests involving
individuals who are intending to and
were bringing firearms to the nation's
capital to be involved directly or
indirectly in the protests
through our partners across the country
were able to identify one individual and
interdict him before he was able to get
close to the city a firearm was seized
charges were laid and he will face full
prosecution including potential jail
time that remains for anybody in this
city or in this country or in any other
country that intends to bring a firearm
to a lawful protest
to engage in unlawful activity in any
way
do not bring weapons do not bring
firearms do not come here to cause harm
do not come here to break the law you
will be held to account
okay we have time for two more questions
uh hi craig lord from global news can
you clarify then do you currently have
intelligence that there are restricted
firearms planned to be in the city this
weekend when the protesters come i'm
going to invite deputy chiefs bell to
provide that intelligence update for you
uh thank you very much for the question
uh in terms of intelligence that we have
for this weekend we are receiving
information have been tracking and
working with our partners we're
anticipating between three to four
hundred trucks attempting to enter to
engage in in the demonstration this
weekend
we also have information that indicates
that there will be between one and two
thousand foot participants who will join
the the area of the demonstration as
well as up to a thousand counter
protesters who have indicated a desire
to come down to the area in terms of
specific intelligence that we have
relating to weapons and firearms we
continue to update the city in terms of
public safety advisories and conduct
investigations in any sort of weapons or
threat related uh information that we
receive thanks for the question
and the last question
hi chief it's joanne canelo from cbc
news um
chief uh i'm sure a lot of people are
very happy to hear there are efforts
being made to stop trucks coming into
the corps people have asked why that
didn't happen last weekend you told us
that was impossible both through the
charter and logistically
like what's changed
joanne thank you very much for the
question
uh we cannot block off the entire city
we cannot stop anybody that wants to
bring a vehicle or conveyance into the
city or walk into the city
this is the nation's capital it's a
democratic society and we have a charter
of lights all of which you've stated we
did block roads we did reduce access we
did create zones where people could park
vehicles outside of the core but the
number of people the number of vehicles
and the number of access and egress
points in the city this is the largest
geographic city in the country the
second largest geographic city in north
america there is no way a police service
of our size or any size could block off
the entire city and stop that even if it
was legal we're taking more steps this
week thank you very much for taking more
steps this week i'm going to invite
deputy chief trish ferguson to speak
about the traffic plan and the hardening
of the downtown core there will be more
closures it will create more problems
and traffic chaos for health care
workers emergency service providers city
workers business owners and people that
want to transverse through the city
there will be a price to pay for higher
security footprint
that is what we're trying to balance on
a constant basis i'll invite deputy
chief ferguson
before you go i just want to say i
didn't ask about the whole city of
course you can't bring everyone every
part in but how come they weren't
stopped trucks from coming into the core
where they are now and getting hurt and
being difficult to remove them now
good morning
to it
i'll begin comments in french and then
we'll switch to english
please
material
last weekend we had over 8 000 people
and thousands of trucks attend
demonstrations in the downtown floor
we have since made significant progress
in reducing this number through
enforcement and patient negotiations
during the past week
we know more demonstrators plan to come
and want to be very clear that they
should stay home
based on our experience over the last
week we are implementing a range of
tactical measures to keep ottawa
residents safe
and prevent further unlawful activity
we are deploying all available police
resources
residents and demonstrators will see a
surge in on-duty officers in the
downtown neighborhoods of centertown
lower town and the byward market
on the ground this will represent an
officer on every street corner to fully
enforce all unlawful acts
officers have received zero tolerance
enforcement directives with full
authority to pursue the strictest
possible
punishments
for traffic violations
mischief
hate crimes
harassment
spitting intimidation and or menacing
behavior
to address incoming traffic we are
utilizing hundreds of concrete and heavy
equipment barricades to create
non-access roadways throughout
centertown and the byward market
the city of ottawa will further share
information on this initiative later
today
we are working to ensure the flow of
traffic but it may be necessary at times
to close the inter-provincial bridges
our negotiators have also communicated
designated parking zones to
demonstration organizers
the efforts of the ottawa police service
this weekend will be focused on the
unlawful behavior connected to the
demonstrations
and the possible influx of demonstrators
the ongoing occupation of the
parliamentary precinct
remains unsolved
unresolved and we are working with all
policing partners including the rcmp the
opp
to re to remove these vehicles as safely
and as quickly as possible
our top priority is to bring these
demonstrations to an end
i'll now turn it over to deputy chief
steve bell who will speak more about
what to anticipate this weekend as well
as our investigative actions given that
you're having time for an announcement
can we have more questions please yeah
so
uh deputy advertising can take two
questions
thank you
so as i indicated before from the start
of the convoy we've been working with
partners to gather intelligence and
evidence on the ongoings of the
situation we continue to work with the
rcmp
the opp the sq and the gatineau police
to gather and disseminate real-time
intelligence information that's
supporting our ongoing operations
that intelligence is current currently
telling us the following we can expect
to see an increase in vehicular traffic
to the downtown core beginning on
saturday and increasing over the weekend
with again an anticipated decline of
that traffic on monday
we're also anticipating several
protesters will attend on foot to gather
in the area our information indicates
that large groups of people who are both
in support of the convoy as well as
opposed to them continuing to be in the
city will gather in the parliamentary
precinct
we anticipate that these lawful
demonstrators will continue in the
downtown core throughout the weekend
on the ground investigative teams will
continue to collect and pursue all
available evidence of any illegal
activity this includes the collection of
license plate numbers
firsthand accounts and witness recounts
social media information and physical
evidence of any wrongdoing in the city
there is currently an underreporting of
some crimes of the unlawful
demonstrators to our residents we
implore you to please respond and report
any unlawful behavior that you are
witnessing or a victim of
every unlawful act including traffic
violations will be fully pursued
in doing so we're working closely with
our policing and intelligent partners
across the country
if you come to our city and commit a
crime we will investigate you we will
find you and we will charge you thank
you
is it okay if i asked my question in
french
[Music]
okay
you for taking some more questions chief
i just want to go back to my original
question
how do you explain to residents
why police are facilitating for example
the transport of jerry kansas fuel and
why it appears that the stockpiling of
fuel which is dangerous but also allows
the protesters to harden and to stay
appears to be condoned by the police
thank you very much
this has been as i've said many times as
my colleagues across the country
who are
managing similar demonstrations nothing
in terms of the size and the scale so
far to date we'll see what happens in
the gta on the weekend
um this is an unprecedented and unusual
set of circumstances the level of
organization
funding
commitment communication
this is we have found at least two
operation centers right here in the city
there are multiple operation centers
across the country and internationally
funding is coming in locally nationally
and internationally
supports including legal advice
logistics support and yes fuel support
are coming in from all sectors and all
sides
we have done absolutely our best to
ensure that we cut off such supports we
isolate and contain the demonstration to
the footprint that it is we've managed
to reduce that footprint over the last
week and we'll do everything we can
including the efforts you just heard
from my deputies to continue to do that
there is no facilitation
of food
water
fuel
logistics or funding by any member of
this police service or any other police
service that i am aware of
let me repeat
there is no supply of food
water
fuel logistics or anything else that
relates to enabling this demonstration
by any member of the ottawa police
service or any other police service that
i am aware of
should that information come to me
you can be clear as chief of police in
this service i will conduct a full
investigation
i will use the full extent of the police
service act and if relevant the criminal
code to pursue charges against such a
member who would do that
hopefully that answers the question
one more jeep outside of you in the
mayor i can't find anyone in the city
who describes what the police has done
so far as the success there's been
people counter-protesting outside of
this police station right here at
different points in time so why should
those counter protesters and why should
the million residents of this city think
that the new measures that you're going
to do
are going to change anything and that
the outcomes will be any different than
what they've seen before thank you very
much for your question again i just want
to reinforce the deep empathy i have
for those who have suffered in any way
particularly those who have been
suffering the most over the last several
weeks
i will tell you that
that empathy comes from a practical
experience that i have in this matter as
well
i too am a victim of a criminal offense
death threats against me in the last 48
hours death threats against city
officials in the last 48 hours the
deputy chief bell and his team are
investigating
while we've been handling this crisis
over the last 12 days straight working
12 14 18 hours a day people like myself
counselors and other public officials
have had to look after the personal
safety of themselves and their families
in their home while managing this this
is impacting everybody and some people
very directly i have deep personal
empathy for those that are suffering we
are doing everything we can to make sure
we keep the city safe every resident
safe every business safe but this is an
unprecedented demonstration that is
happening here it has connections
locally provincially nationally and
internationally we are literally
learning lessons every day we are
getting new intelligence every day new
allies in terms of national and
international security agencies are
aiding us in understanding the depth and
complexity
the resilience of what we're up against
so we can make changes in real time i've
announced today real time massive
changes
150 officers surging into the three
impacted neighborhoods of centertown
lower town and the market on a 24 7
patrol focused on unlawful unacceptable
violent behavior affecting those
neighborhoods we have significantly
increased resources from provincial and
federal sources as well as our municipal
partners and we have new engaged allies
at all three levels of government and
across civil society it is that combined
effort that will continue the success to
date that we've had i will tell you the
first question a member of the media
asked me 12 days ago when it was clear
that this would be a sizable
demonstration coming to the nation's
capital
the very first question asked me by a
member of the media chief how will you
stop what happened on january 6 in
washington dc in 2020
and i got to tell you
that was stopped
now we've got a lot of unacceptable and
unlawful activities in addition to the
death injury and full riots that we saw
south of the border a year ago in almost
the same circumstances
i take no solace in that success i learn
from that and i learn from the mistakes
made
i gather more information i gather more
resources i gather more allies and every
day we wake up and try to do it better
we need to do it better and we will do
it better thank you very much for your
question
i think that's the two questions thank
you very much for watching
right there
yeah i'll get it
okay
that's all the time we have situated
we will be taking one-on-ones with
deputy bell and deputy ferguson
ferguson
ferguson the english ones will
facilitate with
deputy chief bill thank you
okay